in an important senate race arizona
senator martha mcsally's opponent
democrat mark kelly
is doing major damage control tonight
after it was revealed his deputy press
secretary
referred to police as quote worthless
effing
pigs the tweet was posted in august even
before
the staffer joined kelly's campaign both
kelly and the staffer have apologized
he wasn't fired the tweet is deleted
here with reaction
arizona senator martin mcsally um if
that was the person was on your campaign
would you fire them because if they work
for me i'd fire them
well they wouldn't be working for me
sean but i would fire them right away
and keep in mind
this man tweeted this out the week
before
he was hired by mark kelly to be his
spokesman
he hired him anyway the tweet was out
there until they just got caught
he's not fired him and he's still in his
circle i mean you're known by the
company that you keep
and this is no surprise coming from mark
kelly he refused to shake the hand of a
border patrol agent
he's in minneapolis supporting ilhan
omar and helping her to get elected
i back the blue i've got the endorsement
of the arizona not
why he available get elected and why we
need all hands on deck to hold this seat
and the senate majority
uh okay what are his problems with china
because he's got his own issues like
zero
uh experience hunter
yeah he does so while he was in the
military he went over on an all-expense
paid junket by the chinese communist
propaganda arm he said it was the most
meaningful thing he did in his life went
back in 2004 back in 2005.
then he went to space and brought the
chinese communist banner with him to
space
he was so honored and then later he
profited off
these relationships he got 10 cent which
is a company
tied to the chinese government known as
a national security threat
went over there to get them to invest in
a company that he
co-founded this is one of many of his
financial ties like many of the elite in
america
i'm standing up to china with president
trump i'm leading the effort to hold
them accountable
financially for unleashing covet on us
and bringing our jobs home
and my opponents got multiple business
entanglements with him
uh senator uh we're following your race
closely we wish you the best of luck
thanks for joining us